salut aujourd'hui j'entame mon troisième
mois de mental blog huy j'entame ce soir
parce qu'en fait on est mardi soir alors
que c'est la vidéo du mercredi qui
retour quand même sur ces deux mois
écoulés
j'entame le troisième mois donc ça veut
dire que je commence à prendre
conscience de l'ampleur un peu du délire
parce que vraiment il arrive des trucs
cool grâce au mental blog je vous
rencontre souvent durant les spectacles
aux hallucinations collectives ou sur
mon spectacle en tournée
d'ailleurs ce samedi là le seul 10,5 je
serai à la valette du var dans le sud si
vous êtes dans le coin venus au
spectacle on fera une vidéo après ça ce
sera cool ce sera la vidéo du lundi du
coup celle que je mettrais lundi et puis
sinon c'est quand même un petit peu
tendu en fait d'être en flux tendu
justement parce que je fais toujours la
vidéo en temps réel parce que j'en ai
pas d'avant ce qui veut dire qu'il faut
toujours que je pense à la vidéo du
lendemain et ce week-end dit surprise je
suis tombé malade j'étais malade samedi
et dimanche j'espère que ça s'est pas
trop vu dans les vidéos mais j'étais
vraiment voilà samedi dimanche lundi
ça m'a mis un coup en fait et encore
j'étais quand même en capacité de
pouvoir produire des vidéos mais je me
suis dit comment ça va se passer le jour
où vraiment je pourrais pas bougé que le
pas essayer de mentaliser les micros
dans le film ans depuis mon lit c'est
pas possible ça alors je crois que je
vais tourner davance quand j'aurais le
temps parce que ça fait un truc en plus
à faire on s'en sortira jamais de faire
je pense une série de quatre ou cinq
vidéos sur comment résoudre un rubik's
cube très facilement en toute sa vie tu
as la méthode de résolution de rubik's
cube et le jour où je serai très malade
parce que ça peut arriver en fait je
n'ai pas pensé mais ça peut arriver mais
j'aurais juste à les mettre en ligne à
faire l'habillage et à les mettre en
ligne
et ce sera une manière de parts et et le
mental blog tout en pouvant prendre
quatre cinq jours de repos si besoin et
j'espère ne pas me avoir besoin en fait
que j'espère ne pas être malade dans ma
vie d'une manière générale sinon on est
à plus de 1600 abonnés on est à toi est
à 1625 je crois 1630 au moment où je
vous parle c'est bon c'est comme ça
si vous êtes abonné à cette chaîne
abonnez vous en cliquant sur le petit
logo qui a dans le coin ça vous pouvez
vous abonner avec ça à 2500 abonnés qui
monte depuis 2500 on en profitera pour
organiser un apéro en live en fait un
apéro virtuel bien sûr puisque chacun
sera chez soi avec des soft l'abus
d'alcool est dangereux pour la santé
et on brasse parler discuter durant
quelques heures sur des trucs de
mentalisme directement en direct comme
ça voilà pour ce petit point rega mais
aujourd'hui je vous donne donc une
astuce parce que ça de mercredi c'est le
jour des astuces et je vous donne
l'astuce du post-it plusieurs fois dans
les commentaires vous m'avez demandé si
j'avais des astuces pour gagner au jus
du possible bien sûr que les deux
astuces pour ça
mais quatre astuces pour gagner plus
facilement au jeu du post il pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas logique du post
il se joue à plusieurs chaque personne
doit recevoir un post it sur son front
sur lequel il y aura marqué un nom que
tout le monde connaît ça peut être
quelqu'un de très connu deux célèbres
comme ça peut être quelqu'un de sa
famille comme ça peut être quelqu'un de
virtuel comme dieu par exemple ça peut
être
homer simpson voilà peu importe donc
chaque personne un nom comme ça de
coller sur son front et doit retrouver
qui il est qui écrit le nom sur le post
it et bien un autre joueur le fait
secrètement donc il ya une phase
préparatoire à ce jeu c'est là
qu'intervient la première astuce la
première astuce c'est au lieu de vous
creuser la tête pour savoir qui vous
allez écrire sur le post it pour mettre
à votre voisin en fait à un autre joueur
semblant d'écrire ou de réfléchir mais
identifier celui qui va écrire pour vous
vous dis pas de regarder ce qui va
écrire ça non surtout pas je vous dit de
bien regarder qui est cette personne en
fait essayer d'analyser seuil est de
vous mettre à sa place en fait c'est
forcément quelqu'un que vous connaissez
puisque vous jouez avec donc vous
connaissez c'est quand vous connaissez
ces réactions et vous allez voir comment
elle va réagir en fait est ce qu elle a
une idée tout de suite est-ce qu'elle va
réfléchir un petit peu est-ce que c'est
quelqu'un de plutôt timide quelqu'un de
plutôt fantasque est ce que cette
personne là gros garde les post-it des
autres avant d'écrire le sien parce que
là je vous donne un indice ya de fortes
chances qu'elle s'inspire de ce que les
autres ont écrit tout simplement parce
qu'on agit avec des connexions mentale
une idée on en voit une autre comme pour
les brainstormings eve est là pour ça
c'est pareil on se nourrit en fait de
leur environnement
regarder un petit peu ce qu'il ya dans
la pièce donc regarder cette personne
regarder ce qu'elle regarde ce qu'elle
fait et comment elles pourraient
réfléchir ça c'est déjà un bon indice la
deuxième astuce consiste à déterminer à
l'avancé quelle est la personne la plus
expressive dans les convives puisque
quand vous allez vous posez votre
question par exemple votre question va
être suis un homme
les gens doivent dire oui ou non puisque
dans ce jeu on peut répondre que par oui
ou par non et ça on y reviendra
vous devez déterminer la personne la
plus expressive parce que ces personnes
là très expressive vont vous donner des
réponses avant de formuler et moi ou
assima règle tant que la personne n'a
pas verbaliser le oui ou le don je peux
changer de questions faut pas jouer avec
moi en fait c'est pas une arnaque c'est
tout à fait légal
la règle dit qu'on doit poser une
question qui est personnes doivent
répondre par oui ou par donc temps que
la personne n'a pas répondu
verbalement
vous changez de questions on n'est pas
obligé obligé regarder la personne qui
répond avec son visage soit avec un
mouvement de tête soit avec un sourire
soit avec un pour le nom qui est la plus
expressive et sur qui vous allez pouvoir
lire les réponses avant de verbaliser
qui permet quand vous avez la réponse
est non verbal de dire non non non non
non non je change des questions c'est
pas ça petite astuce qui permet la
troisième astuce consiste à avoir une
vérité qu'en fait c'est vraiment des
astuces embrouille un champ compte
la quatrième sera plus légal la
troisième astuces ça consiste à
reformuler avec une vérité c'est-à-dire
avant de jouer vous faites un petit
récap mais sais tu ne sais pas vraiment
une question un exemple concret c'est au
tour d'avant j'ai demandé si j'étais
célèbre et que les gens ont dit oui
maintenant je vais vouloir savoir si je
suis célèbre qu'en france aussi je suis
célèbre dans le monde entier
mais ça c'est une autre question du coup
je vais reformuler une vérité le fait
que je suis célèbre avec une question en
direct le fait d'inclure le monde entier
et donc là il faut jouer un peu la
comédien a le secret sortez les oscars
dicaprio est parmi nous ok donc là ça
commence à être un peu compliqué donc je
pars du dernier point je suis célèbre
dans le monde entier et donc si je suis
célèbre dans le monde entier c'est parce
que je suis encore une fois vous allez
remarquer sur le visage de votre cible
de l'astuce numéro 2 si c'est bon ou pas
et quand bien même bien souvent il ya
bonheur tu as toujours quelqu'un pour
dire ah non non on n'a pas dit ça dans
certaines soirées on m'a jeté des objets
à force de se rendre compte de ce que je
faisais donc faites le à vos risques et
périls
la quatrième astuces sont les dix
questions que j'ai référencé pour
fabriquer mon entonnoir parce qu'en
réalité ce jeu c'est là il ya tout le
champ des possibles qui vous pouvez être
au départ vous êtes vous même on a pu
écrire votre propre prénom cause dans ah
là là ça va être difficile et c'est un
des plus faciles à trouver
comme vous pouvez être quelqu'un de très
connu ou quelqu'un de fictif comme je
vous ai dit ou encore même le chien du
voisin
vous pouvez être n'importe qui un point
commun vous avez le fait que toutes les
personnes qui jouent au jeu avec vous
connaissent la personne que vous êtes
sur le post it une fois qu'on a joué un
peu au qui s géant dans notre esprit
parmi toutes les possibilités
ça nous permet d'avoir un vrai rails de
penser et de crier et d'aboutir assez
facilement à la réponse je vous donne
les dix questions principales
me permette moi de trouver très très
vite la première question que je pose
c'est est-ce que je suis réel ou fictif
yassa j'exige de la part des autres
joueurs une réponse précise exemple
david duke ovni est réelle mais fox
mulder effectif ma deuxième question
c'est toujours est-ce que je suis connue
ou anonymes est-ce que je suis un homme
ou une femme
ensuite je m'attache à trouver le
secteur en fait où évolue cette personne
donc si c'est quelqu'un de connu je vais
chercher dans le politique dans le
sportif dans l'artistique dans le
religieux si c'est quelqu'un de connu je
vais chercher à savoir si c'est le
cercle amical familial professionnel
une fois que j'ai ça je m'attache encore
autre chose c'est à savoir si la
personne est vivante ou morte
et ben oui ça aussi ça va lui piste
après je pose une question qui surprend
en général mais faites-le ça c'est
intéressant pour notre cher j'ai demandé
mon personnage est composé d'un nom d'un
prénom au juste d'un seul nom au moment
où vous aurez vraiment votre rails ça
vous aidera beaucoup à faire vos choix
en fait pour proposer vos réponses
ensuite je demande si cette personne me
connaît et peut prononcer mon prénom
petite arnaque
il ya encore de questions dans une cette
question n'a évidemment je la peau selon
toutes les réponses que j'ai eue avant
ensuite je commence à gratter pour
essayer de trouver le sou univers du
premier cercle si par exemple on croyait
cercle c'était quelqu'un qui fait partie
de monde du cinéma
je vais je vais chercher si c'est plus
des comédies des westerns des films
d'action des films d'horreur
si c'est quelqu'un qui vient du milieu
de la musique je cherchais si c'est de
la pop du rock du rap etc etc je vais
chercher un peu le souci univers ensuite
je cherche le pays uniquement à ce
moment là je cherche le pays
je cherche le pays si ça pas été
clairement défini en tout cas d'ici là
donc je cherche le pays d'où la personne
vient et si je suis bloqué si je suis
figée ou si un jeu est un petit peu de
temps devant moi d'après moi par rapport
aux autres joueurs
je vais essayer de trouver le nombre de
syllabes qu'il ya dans le nom surtout si
ce qu'il y a décrit sur mon post it est
composée d'un seul mot dans ces cas là
le nombre de syllabes va vraiment
m'aider
après par rapport à toutes les idées qui
vont me dire voilà vous avez toutes mes
astuces en tout cas celles qui sont
reproduits cible pour gagner plus
facilement au jeu du post it amusez vous
mettez moi dans les commentaires ce
qu'on vous a mis deux de pire en fait
comme non quand vous avez joué à ce jeu
là ça ça m'intéresse et puis ça donnera
des idées à tout le monde pour essayer
de piéger les autres joueurs lors d'une
partie merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo si elle vous a plus pensé à
la partager
abonnez-vous à la chaîne voulait dit
c'est important au rendez vous samedi
du var pour ceux qui habitent près de
toulon pour ceux qui se posent la
question pourquoi j'ai fait la vidéo en
avant c'est parce que demain j'ai
rendez-vous et youtube space pour la
première fois et j'ai hâte d'y aller je
vous fais une petite vidéo là bas et
d'ici là rendez vous demain à 17 heures
pour le prochain mentale blog ciao